adoma bonjour alors quelle est
l'ambiance sur place
[Musique]
vous allez manifestation est partie il
ya une heure de la place de la
république en direction de la place de
la bastille on est d'ailleurs assez
proche de cette place le parcours est
relativement court pour cet après-midi
de mobilisation la manifestation vous
allez le voir sur ces images de citéa
lauvergeon elle est souvent à l'arrêt
d'ailleurs c'est le cas à l'heure où je
vous parle et ce qui se passe en fait
c'est que il ya beaucoup de monde
plusieurs milliers de personnes et ils
sont encadrés par un important
dispositif de sécurité
en tête du cortège des gendarmes mobiles
sur les flancs du cortège des serres et
si l'on cadre ils sont très proches des
manifestants et ils sont assez souvent
amenées à s'arrêter à faire des pauses
comme c'est le cas au moment où je vous
parle
et cela provoque quelques tensions
notamment en tête du cortège puisqu'elle
vous l'imaginez les manifestants
souhaitent continuer à avancer ce n'est
pas possible puisqu'ils ont face à eux
des cordons de gendarmes y ait eu
plusieurs tensions
il ya quelques minutes des gendarmes ont
utilisé du gaz lacrymogène pour
disperser la foule puisque et des petits
mouvements de foule qui se créent en
fait deux en tête de ce cortège on sent
une forte tension pour cette
manifestation manifestation vous l'avait
dit pour le personnel hospitalier
notamment qui réclament davantage de
moyens qui ne sont pas convaincus par
les accords du secteur de la santé qui
ont été signés hier d'ailleurs il nous
rappelle que certains syndicats n'ont
pas signé ces accords et puis qu' il
existe aussi une forme de déconnexion
entre la tête des syndicats qui ont
signé hier ces accords et puis la base
qui elle réclame encore davantage de
moyens je propose d'écouter ces
témoignages que nous avons récoltées
tout à l'heure avec cynthia lauvergeon
un cirage de pompes c'est on va embellir
la chose on veut
comment nous faire croire plein de
choses et puis que derrière bas on
rigole un petit peu on fait des pieds de
nez aux tuyaux spitz aux gens
hospitalier enfin les personnels
hospitaliers pardon donc là on doit
d'une petite chose pour calmer le jeu
mais quand tout sera fini on va
continuer le processus et on fermera les
les oreilles de des demandes de tous les
gens personnel hospitalier donc voilà on
est là pour ça et que en fin de compte
qu'on arrête pas tout simplement nous
prendre pour des blaireaux vous l'avez
entendu des manifestants n'ont pas
convaincu par le ségur et qui juge
également que le fait d'avoir invité des
soignants pour les cérémonies ce matin
place de la concorde c'est une opération
de communication ils ne se sentent pas
concernés par ces invitations il réclame
encore une fois plus de moyens notamment
plus de lits - de fermetures de services
et puis au sein de cette manifestation
il n'y a pas que du personnel
hospitalier il ya aussi beaucoup de
gilet jaune des gilets jaunes qui
n'était pas forcément là les samedis de
mobilisation des filets jaunes qui pour
certains d'entre eux viennent de
province ils ont fait le déplacement
spécialement pour cette journée une
journée hautement symbolique le 14
juillet fête nationale
c'était important pour eux d'être
présent aujourd'hui je vous propose à
nouveau de les écouter on a toujours
appelés à converger avec avec le
personnel hospitalier
d'ailleurs nous nous aujourd'hui on
n'est plus chez les jeunes on est
citoyen en colère
voilà parce que ça représente toutes les
luttes et aujourd'hui c'est important de
toutes les luttes convergent ensemble je
prends par exemple les
les patrons de boîte de nuit on aurait
aimé aujourd'hui que les patrons de
boîtes de nuit soit avec nous dans la
rue tous ensemble et je pense que la
grande union des luttes il faut qu'elle
soit maintenant c'est important on
attend la rentrée j'espère que les gens
le reste des gens vont se réveiller
parce que malheureusement c'est toujours
les mêmes qu'on a qu'on a dans la rue et
fo faut réveiller les autres que
s'asseoir ya tellement de trucs qui vont
pas à l'heure d'aujourd'hui qu'on se bat
pas je trouve pas ça normal
voilà donc pour les revendications de
ces gilet jaune qui parfois ne se
désigne plus comme tel mais qui restent
attachés aux revendications qu'il porte
depuis plus d'un an et demi maintenant
voilà donc pour cette manifestation qui
va arriver à bastille dans les toutes
prochaines minutes
quelques tensions encore en tête de ce
cortège un signe qui ne trompe pas les
gendarmes sont équipés d'un casque
désormais signe qu' il ya eu quelques
tensions pour cette manifestation et on
va voir évidemment va suivre avec
attention ce qu'il se passe désormais
que nous arrivons sur cette place de la
bastille à paris
merci à thomas pour toutes ces
précisions et c'était donc des images en
direct de la manifestation de soignants
à paris